welcome everyone to
another topic on mokito junit tutorial
here
now in this one we are going to talk
about like how exactly we can use
both marketer and junit here to go for
the unit testing
but before even talking about these two
tools here let's focus on to
understand like what is exactly a unit
testing here
now there are various kind of testing
which is actually available into our
particular industry
and into our software testing world
there but yes
there is a very important scope and a
position
of the unit testing here so unit testing
is something which
we also call is an kind of a component
testing is actually a software testing
technique
in which single component of a software
is being tested we are not talking about
like how exactly our application is
going to
interact with other applications and
it's going to interact with
uh it's not a complete full-fledged
application testing
so in this case what we are looking
forward is like it
this is something in which we are
focusing on how exactly we can only
validate and test out a single component
a single component is what
we are basically talking about over here
right and uh when we say like how
exactly
uh we want to perform we want to achieve
the setup here
so this is the main uh mechanism or this
is the main kind of testing which
an individual developer performs at its
own end
to see like whatever the piece of source
code he is writing whether it's working
fine
as expected or not so this is where
we are able to see like uh the
exactly what we are trying to achieve
here and
how a full-fledged or a basic testing
validation can be done
now the main objective of this unit
testing is to
pick a unit a very basic small small
unit of
the source code to verify it so that
it will be uh the moment the developer
develops the code base at that moment of
time only this thing will be validated
and will be fixed on so this is
something which we are looking forward
over here
to achieve like how the automation needs
to be done and needs to be achieved over
here in this case
next thing is what exactly is the
marking here now we talked about like
junit here but next one is like
what exactly we are talking about as in
a particular marking over here
now when we talk about mocking so we are
basically
uh trying to understand like what
exactly uh
we are performing for what purpose we
are going for the mocking process here
so mocking refers to the development of
objects
which are mock or clone of real objects
they are not the exact uh objects or we
can say like that's not the exact
scenario which we are going to implement
but it's kind of a duplicate or it's
kind of a temporary marks which we are
creating
so that we will be able to get it
implemented so
mocking is something which is kind of a
reference or a kind of a clone of an
existing or a real object here so in
this technique
what happens that the mock objects are
being used instead of the actual real
object so it's not like we are directly
or we are going to access the exact real
objects over here
so we are talking about like uh using or
going through the
uh specific mock objects over here in
this one so that's where we are putting
up the
main focus right and mock objects
actually give a particular output uh
for each and every input whatever the
inputs your pro you are going to provide
you are going to get any particular
desired output so
the marking is going to process all
these inputs
give you the desired output and to
understand like how the
implementations and the setups can be
done right
so for this kind of mocking process
mocking a framework
is something which is quite popular so
marketer is one of the framework which
is available there
which uh is desired for this kind of uh
work or this kind of approach only
where we are trying to see like how we
are we want to perform a mocking
implementation over here right so let's
talk about the marketer tool because
that's a primary tool which is there for
the
mocking activity and we have already
focused on like marketing is and process
in which
we are uh trying to uh process uh the
mock objects rather than the real
objects so that's kind of
uh verification here so marketo is a
kind of a job is framework which is
being used for
uh doing the unit testing on the java
application so
if you have written the source code in
java programming language then marketer
is a kind of a framework for you
so this is something which is helpful
for validating the development of the
um kind of application source code here
so you will be able to validate that how
your application is going to behave
and it's going to work so when we talk
about market market over here so it
basically gives you a variety of
information like what exactly approach
you are looking forward
and what is the end result you are
trying to establish over here
so that's the main focus of the mokito
which we are going to get
and it's for the basic uh approach over
here
so java reflection api is basically used
uh internally to generate the mark
objects that's a
core component you can say like the
backbone of this whole uh
mocking approach over here mokito is
used to simplify the test
development by marking the external
dependencies
and using them in the source code so
it's kind of a
blending in the whole environment there
so that your application is going to get
the desired
environment and uh being in that
environment it can
start processing the inputs and then
give the desired output accordingly
so this is what we are trying to uh you
know implement as such over here to see
like how
exactly this mocking can be done and
mockito can
really help us in this approach here
right now what are the different
prerequisites which we require to learn
more
though so we basically need two
important p request over here
first of all we need the hands-on
experience in java programming language
so java programming language is very
important
because mokito is something which we can
write in the java programming language
it uses the
java programming language syntax so
that's a very important thing there to
be considered
and second one is the junit framework
implementation so these two things we
basically require
for performing a complete full-fledged
market approach or mocking
testing over here so these are the two
important uh
components or you can say like the two
core pre-requests which we need to
process before going for the
mokito implementation right so let's go
to see understand like how mokito
framework can be configured in eclipse
because
eclipse is the prime tool for creating
the uh development source code for the
java programming language
so we need to see like how we can
configure the emojito framework over
there because that's the one
that's a single ide which will be
utilized by the developers there so
let's go ahead in that in this demo we
are going to talk about like how
we can create a simple uh junit and
mokito related
uh program over here so that we can have
a basic project created
and we can also have some basic program
created on that part so
let me open the eclipse here now in this
one what i'm going to do is like first
of all i'm going to
create a maven project once my maven
project is created then i'm going to
include
mokito and junit related dependencies
and
after that i'm going to write up very
small source code
just to see like how exactly our
dependencies are getting dissolved and
my source code which will come up as an
error earlier will come up as unhealthy
over there
so all i have to do is i have to just
right click over here
new and here i need to go for project
like i want to go for a particular
maven project here so i can expand the
maven over here
and go for maven project here it will
basically ask me certain values
uh i want to use the default workspace
location
so i'll just say next um then i want to
have it uh like i want to go ahead with
this overall process so these are all
projects
like what exactly uh you know archetype
you architecture type you want to go so
i can just go for the default whatever
is selected i can just go with that
and here i will be providing like what
is a group id so i can provide a group
id called com.simplylearn or depending
on your organization you can actually
provide it
so here i can provide market to and the
version will be like this and
this is the same way like how the
project will also be created the package
will be created in case of the
project here so then i'll just say
finish
and uh on the left hand side i will be
able to see like my
uh specific source code which is
available there so this is something
which
is uh going to come up over here so it's
actually trying to uh resolve some of
the
particular options like some of the uh
you know like uh the components like
test executions
those are required over here so i'll
just uh
go for this particular reservation later
on
right so i'll just open this palm.xml
file here
and this is the bom xml file right so
it's basically
looking forward for certain changes like
this jar file so this jar file is not
actually available over here so once i
ran the build and you know those kind of
setup can be done
then it will be able to download those
particular dependencies
so if you right click on this one you
will be able to see that
particular maven build option here so i
can just run the maven build or
you can just run the movement clean here
so according to that the maven will be
downloading certain plugins and they're
just trying to do some
uh particular process over here so on
the left hand side the source
main test the same package
which is available there the same
packages is coming up there so
app test is available there so here the
test
is being available here i can see like
some couple of junit related test cases
is already being there like
i created a kind of a sample project so
in here
a basic java and a basic uh class file
or a test suite is already being
available here
so all i have to do is like i have to
just try to see like if i can go ahead
with this uh executions there
now it's using like junit uh 3.8.1 over
here so i can definitely go for a
version
which is uh higher like around junit
four or five there but let me try to do
a clean build over here maven build over
here so
uh to see like if it really works on
there so
uh what are the goals i need to do i
need to go for the goals called clean
install
so that's a goal which we need to do
here so uh
mvn will automatically be resolved there
but clean install is the goal which i
want to look forward over here
so let's see like what it really happens
so it's going to download some couple of
plugins whatever the plugins i'm trying
to provide here
some dependent plugins will be
downloading so all that stuff will be
downloaded
this is the first time we are running
there so that's why it made download
some little bit
more uh jar files than expected ones
not you must have seen like these are
all jar files is not like something we
are using into our project
but these are kind of for jar files
which is being used by the plugins
by the maven itself so for that purpose
it's actually going to that particular
level
but once these are cached up there next
time if you do the run
if you do any kind of burst there you
are not going to see all these
entries so let me rerun the build here
to show you like how clean the output
would be there
so i can just go for clean install again
and say run
and this time the output which will be a
little bit less there so
in this case as you can see if i expand
the
output so here first of all it ran
like it performed the clean activity
then it compiled my source code here
it also compiled my test cases here in
this one
then my test cases got executed over
here so you can see like
it's something which got xx executable
over here so this is the test which is
available
i can click on that and i can see that
and after that uh
it went on and prepared the final
artifact here
which also means like it performs both
the compilation and the test cases
execution
and this is what we are doing in any
kind of movement project
and on top of that i'm using a j-unit
related frameworks
so this is a mechanism where we can have
some dependencies like i can go for
j-unit here
i can increase the dependencies i can
try out the pair so all that stuff i can
do here
right and one more dependency which i
can include is of the marketer here
so i can uh include the marketo related
dependency also over here
so that uh we can see like how exactly
the response is coming up there
so you can see like it's uh you know
when i go for the resolution over here
like clean build
clean install so i can just go ahead
with this
so this time it's actually going for the
mokito one so
you can see like all the steps has been
executed
and we have got the end result so the
build is successful
and i have got the test cases also so
this is the test file where i'm actually
loading up some junit related uh
executables there so i can just go with
that and
whatever the activity assert we are
using over here
so using which we can do the comparison
so this is a way like how
a basic project can be created in maven
and on top of that how we can manage the
dependencies for mokito
and for change unit here right so that
was a demo
in which we talked about like how
exactly we can configure mokito into our
eclipse here
now let's see like when exactly we
require the marketer to be implemented
now in this case what happens like uh
when when exactly you feel like you need
to have a mokito implementation
or how we can go for the mokito
implementation all together here
so for example when a component is to be
tested or a single unit needs to be
tested
so this unit or component actually
depends on some other component
which is a kind of uh in intelligent
process or maybe some other developer
owns that component
and you are not exactly validating that
component you are validating your
own component but since it's actually
dependent on other
component or some other unit of the of
the whole
application so that's the reason why you
may not be going
you may not be able to perform the
end-to-end testing but yes
with the help of mokito you will be able
to get the mock objects
so that you can perform the testing
there you don't have to held up
with that other component dependency you
can resolve
all these dependencies like that and you
can just
proceed further with your verification
and your
implementation so this is the main
benefit which you get when you talk
about the marketer so that you can get
see that a full-fledged understanding
like how exactly these different
components are going to be processed
here
right and uh when there is any kind of
concern like uh
if if uh you know like if you feel like
there are some infrastructure components
which is making the testing impossible
so in that case also we can use the
marketer to mark some infrastructure
components
so that we can proceed further with the
validation and the testing here
so all the hindrances and all the
problems which we normally face
when we talk about the implementation
all those things can be
really implemented with the help of
mokito here so that's the main benefit
which you get over here in this one now
let's talk about the next concept so the
next concept which we have is
what exactly is a stub very important
concept here so
stub is a kind of object which
holds up a predefined information a
predefined data we cannot do a kind of a
dynamic
verification in case of unit testing
because we have to
uh limit the scope of testing we are
putting up some inputs over here just to
see like how our application is going to
behave
these predefined data will act like
inputs
and uh the test cases are going to
process these inputs
and give us the desired output so these
outputs we will be then analyzing to
understand that how our application is
going to behave
or in other terms like how application
is reacting to these inputs
so that we can get an end-to-end desired
output as such here
also it can be referred to as an object
that looks like
exactly a carbon copy of a real object
of course it's not a real object it's a
kind of
a mock object over here in this one but
it will give you the exact different
details or you can say like things that
output as such over here in this one
so that's a main benefit which we get
with the stuff that it helps us to get a
mock object instead of the real object
so that we can get ahead with the
testing and we can get
all our environment for our test
executions here
right and stubs actually they can
actually return
the specific output here like whatever
the
output you require so that will be
returned over here whatever the inputs
you provide that
is going to be processed by this one and
the desired output will be provided
to you over here in this one now these
stubs
are used to reduce the complexities
right so that
occur while uh creating the real object
so that's
also the complexity which is going to be
reduced when we talked about the
uh these specific stubs as such here so
whenever we talk about these tabs we
talk about the implementation so this is
where the
complexities get reduced when we talk
about the uh
replication or the marking of the real
objects here
right so let's talk about like how we
can see the
stub in real action so that we can get a
better understanding because from there
we will be able to know like what is the
mean uh importance of stub in the whole
mocking approach here so let's go ahead
with that in this demo we are going to
talk about
like how we can create some pre-request
for testing out a stub here
so i'm going to create a required maven
project and a
couple of class files over here to make
a kind of
environment so that we can test it out
the stub implementation in mokito
so first what i need to do is like i
need to just go ahead with the maven
project
so movement project is what i need to
create a very basic project i want to
create over here
you don't have to do much of the changes
like not uh much
things you need to talk about over here
so uh
the package direction i can make it like
uh okay i just want the particular
package
if if you don't want to have the package
and you would want to directly store the
source code in
source means java and you want to put
the class directly over there
without having any kind of uh particular
comm and all that stuff so you can do
that also over here in this case so that
will be much faster so you then you can
just go for the finish here
and you will be able to see like a
project created
like a source main java then uh this
particular
package name is there and source uh test
java
is also there so here is the test file
here is the main file
i i can go ahead with this one i can
create a file over here
you can pretty much do that stuff also
so or you can change like
this existing one also so what i'm going
to do is like i'm going to
create a new class file here so i'm
going to say like okay create new class
file
and in this one i'm going to put the
particular
class name and a specific content so uh
let's
see like how exactly we can go so we can
go for a particular
uh class creations as such here or we
want to
create so one class and one interface we
want to create so that we will be
creating over here
so i'm going to create an interface here
right so
to to surface
so that's the interface name which i'm
trying to provide here
and uh in this one
i'm just pasting the content
so this is already configured here so
i just have to configure like this right
so uh then i'm just going to resolve
this one so the
java.util.list is also resolved so this
is the to do service.java which is
available there
now what i have to do is like i i'm just
trying to create it over here
and i'm just uh trying to create an
another class file over here in this one
so which is like my to do business impl
over here which will be using this
interface
right so i'm going to create
a particular class file in this one
and we are going to create it
okay great so in this one again i'm
going to
paste this content so i have to
just sync this one so
this is what so i have to just rename it
a little bit
of this one so i have to just
rename as in particular this as
over here great so
now uh i'm pretty much done here so
whatever the inputs are required
i can actually go it just this delta i
want to remove it
and uh here we go so we are creating a
particular to do
service mechanism over here in this one
so
we are also talking about the
uh list here so these list where i can
go for the auto resolution here so i'm
just going to save it
and uh then i'm going to see like for to
do
here so to do is something which is
coming up as an
particular uh service here so a little
bit
changes in this uh interface also so
i can just you just have to sync it on
the names
so uh whatever name you are following
you are using so that you need to
change over here in this case so here
also in due to service i have got it
renamed
so that's where it got successfully
resolved and
as far as the error list is confirmed so
i can just import that also
so i'm just done here so if you by
chance change this
class name then you change the java file
name also calling there
so that you will be there in proper sync
up over here
so that's uh something uh which is
available there which we can use to see
like how the implementation can be done
and that's a basic output which you're
getting over here now this is where we
have got all the required source code
available there when we will be testing
out the stub
so at that time we can actually use
these one interface and one class over
here so this class is basically going
for the interface call over here in this
one and that's how it's going on the
implementation
so we'll come back during the testing
during the verification of this stuff
at that moment of time this will act as
a kind of basis for us here so this is a
kind of basic structure that how you
create a basic
uh program or a basic source code over
here in this one so what i'm going to do
is like i'm going to just create
these stubs over here in this one to
test it out to validate that the
things there so last time we created the
java source codes here now the stubs we
will be creating
over here in this one then we are just
trying to
create first one is for the to do
service
so to do service
stop so that's the name which i'm going
to use and just finish it off
and uh i'm just going to put the content
over here
so just in order to try out the
particular matching over here in this
one
so uh to do stub is what we are trying
to implement so that's what we are going
to see here so i'm just going to remove
uh this mechanism so i'm able to see
like all the imports is working fine
uh in this case we are just trying to
put some
a dummy information so you can see like
this is the array this is the error list
content which we are trying to provide
over here in this stuff
so we are basically trying to understand
like how in the marking activity
we are trying to mark some particular
inputs here so that
my stubs will be able to pick those up
and they will be able to return those
there
so that's what we are trying to do here
now as far as this uh stub is
uh configured this is done so we have to
go for an another stub here which will
be there for the to do business impl
so we have to create uh this one for uh
that
particular implementation so we
have to put the content over here in
this one to do to put the two
uh do business impl stop here right so
i'm going to paste the content here
just to just to match up the things so i
have to
uh just put this content here so i have
to just rename this one
because even if we create some files
sometimes
we may have to rename it so that keeping
in mind i can
just put this one here and say okay and
uh
i'm just going to remove this component
here and here we go
so we have got like uh these components
like this is something which is
available there
we have got the implementations which we
are trying to do
we have got to do service and to do
service stuff both
here but i can these are the
kind of wrong interfaces so idly my
interfaces
is com dot
simply learn dot stub
so that's where we have got the
particular to do service over there and
similarly here also we have got the
particular ones which is available so
which is also there in the
specific com.simplylearn.stop.to do
service stub here
so this is a mechanism where we will be
able to find out even if i don't give
this import that's totally fine because
i'm already there in that package so i
can just refer it from there
and we also have the junit related ones
which is available there so we are
getting the
errors for the j-unit uh components over
here in this case
so we also have the pom.xml file here in
which my junit is being utilized
so uh you know in this one we are
basically trying to use
some references around the j unit here
so you can get it
on board on that case so i can just try
to run on the
particular movement build here to see
like if all the dependencies are getting
implemented
so that we will be able to
download some required dependencies so
clean install
again i'm going to just refer it over
here i can just uh run the
specific test also like if i feel but
i'm just trying to download some couple
of
components over here in this case so if
there is any kind of issues which you
are getting during the execution so you
will be able to see over here
for instance like oij.junit does not
exist over there
right so since these packages are not
downloaded or not installed so that's
why you're getting the issues
as such over here in this case right
so these are the uh references which is
available there i can just go ahead
and import some of the
junit related ones in this case
if i feel like i want to run it so i can
run this java file also over here this
file also i can run it over here
right so those are different options
which is available which we can utilize
in this case
so i'm just adding the junit 4 library
so that my uh all references related to
junit should be resolved here
and the moment i picked up that one you
can see like all the
errors related to j unit is gone now i
can run my build here
to see like if it's getting successful
so this time
okay so uh it's it's going for that
particular mechanism so
i can change the specific
uh version as in 4.0 let's see like
uh it's getting resolved so it should be
able to download that particular
artifact so i just have to find out that
what is the version what is the latest
version we want to provide
and according to that the artifacts will
be there and it will be executed
so uh there are some cases when we are
using uh
the default mechanism of creating a
junit or um even project in
eclipse sometimes it actually uses an
older version so it was using 3.8.1
version
which is old version so i'm using 4.0 so
this source code is actually prepared
according to 4.0
and the moment i started using that the
moment i tried on that one there
so you can see like here it got executed
like both the test cases got executed
over here
i have got the response over here in
this one like these two test cases
is being provided over here so test run
is two there is no failure
all good and then ultimately it went on
to the jar file preparation here
so this is a way like how the stub is
actually going to uh particular
uh you know it's going to call the
particular specific classes but
yes in this case we are just trying to
input some values
some static values which is not the real
objects but it's kind of a mock
often a real object and that's how we
are going to continue with our test
cases
just to see like you know some inputs if
they are not there we can still
go for the testing and we can do the
verification here
so this is a mechanism like how we can
test out a stub
to go to see like to understand how the
overall marking
is going to happen here so that was the
main uh
implementation on how this a stub can be
implemented in the whole process
to see like how exactly we can go ahead
with them now the next
demo which we are going to talk about is
like how we can full fledge
implement the complete marketer code
here so that the end-to-end
implementation of the marking of real
objects
is what we can get over here in this one
so this will give us the complete
insight about this whole process
now first we will be creating a specific
uh we are taking up a stock inventory
kind of
example over here so we are going to
create a java file over here which is
named as stock.java so i'm just going to
create a class file here
called stock
and in that case we will be providing
the content here
so i'm going to create a stock class
which is having
certain methods certain functions stock
is the main function which is available
there
now we have to create a particular
interface which is going to
you which is going to be used to get the
stock there and uh
then ultimately at last we will be
getting a one test file which will be
testing out this thing the communication
and see like if the marketer is getting
passed or the test case is getting
passed or not
so this is the class file which is
available there get stock id
set stock id so basic getter and setters
are being used
used over here in this case so now i
have to create a particular interface
here
with the name called stock service
and in this case i have to
call the get
price over there so get price is
basically configured over here in this
one
right so we are going to just call upon
on that to see like how exactly it goes
out there
right so we will be utilizing this one
so this is the
interface which is calling up the class
called stock.java
now once the stock main class in stock
service or stock interface has been
created
now we have to create a particular
portfolio class here
this portfolio is a kind of interface
which is going to
consume this specific stock here so
portfolio
class is what we are going to create
here so i'm just going to use it
and it's using some list operation so
i'm going to just import the java.util
also
so that these can be imported so these
are some couple of uh
activities like under this one we are
also calling up these
stock service interface so that that can
be calling up the stock internally
and this is kind of a business logic
which is happening so
portfolio.java is kind of a business
logic business layer where i'm just
trying to call them the main class there
to fetch the details
through an interface and in this one we
are basically doing the
all processing like whatever the
activities i'm trying to do
so here i'm doing the processing about
the data here right
so this is what we have uh from the
source code perspective now we will be
moving on to the test cases perspective
where we will be
writing a test file to uh do the mocking
over here
and to get the stocks and try to do some
verification
so now i'm going to create a particular
portfolio tester here
which will be testing this
specific uh portfolio here so that's
what we are going to do
right so it's going to use some of the
mokito related uh
jar files here and since we already have
those uh dependencies like the we
already got those
added up to our palm.xml file so and
these are also being shown up as an
maven dependency here so both 4.0 and
this market to dependency is there in
the maven dependencies
and that's why we are not getting any
errors for these imports here
and we are getting some list related
errors so let me import those also
and we should be fine by now here so as
you can see like here we
are when we are doing the verification
right
so using this portfolio tester we are
actually inducing
some stacks so here you can see like we
are doing some setup
we are calling that stock service over
here so that we will be able to call
upon or we will be able to get the
information and here we are actually
putting up some content
so the whole idea why we are putting up
this content just to
uh have the implementation we are just
trying to
replicate uh real objects here uh these
are not the actual real uh
configurations or real information which
we are getting from the
uh end users but these are the the dummy
informations or the dummy data
which we are trying to provide here and
depending on that we will be able to get
like how it's going on there so we are
basically trying to
call a function called tester.setup
there tester.setup is what we are trying
to
call upon over here which will set up
the initial information
and then we are calling the test market
value so my test market value will
basically give me
a a pass or fail kind of uh
result set here so that depending on
that i can decide that whether it's
successful or not
and this test market value only here we
are putting up some dummy informations
and against these dummy informations the
test cases will be executed
so let's just run it my build is already
success so i don't have to run it again
there
so what i need to do is like i need to
go for this portfolio tester
dot java here so that i will be able to
get the results
and here we go we are getting the pass
output over here in this one right
so this is what we are trying to do just
to see like how the implementation
should be done there
i can go for a negative scenario like
where i can just a little bit
modify uh something over here in the
output
and uh i'm just trying to change a
little bit of uh specific
uh output so that's what i'm trying to
do here so um
i can definitely go and see like if this
is something going to
uh process properly or is there any kind
of problem which we are getting over
here
i can also remove this decimal value
just to see like if uh
i'm getting successful over here or not
so i'm just running the
test cases again and here we go we got
the response as in failure
because the expected thing is not coming
up like whatever we are returning
so that's where the failed uh it's going
down for the failure
i'm going to roll back my things here
and see like if it's again getting
success or not
so yes here we go we got the pass
success over here the past status over
here in this one
so just like that you can actually mock
the objects you can put some inputs and
according to that the responses will be
coming up there
and you can go ahead with that
particular mechanism so this is the way
that how
the things really gets moved on when we
talk about the
uh marketer and how we can mark the real
objects
and we can uh test out our application
here
so that's what we do with the market
okay so that was a complete uh
marketo code or you can see like a
complete demo over here like how the
overall process really gets implemented
over here in this one
right now what are the different
benefits of mokito let's process that
one by one so
the main benefits of mokito is like
first of all we'll get started with the
very first one
is like the no handwriting
so that's a very first benefit which is
coming up over here
now second one is the object creation
third one is the safe refactoring
then we have an exception support uh
benefit which we get over here
then we have got like the annotation
support which is available there
and then the order support so these are
some couple of benefits which we got
over here
to completely understand like how
exactly the
uh particular mokito can be really
achieved over here in this one
right so this is the real benefits of
market to here
so that's it for this guys so i hope you
liked it thanks
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here